كما نشاهد هنا وصول شهيدين الى مستشفى
كمال عدوان نتيجه القصف المدفعي المستمر
على بيت حنون قبل قليل تم انتشال هؤلاء
الشهداء من قبل
الاهالي في منطقه بيت
حنون لقيناهم ا اول شارع شارع القرمان
الشهدا اثنين حملناهم و
جبناهم الله يرحمهم والله ما عارفين من هم
اصلا اه حرمه
حرمه اه حرمه الله يرحمه ربنا يتقبله ان
شاء الله هذا طريقنا و ضربنا صار ضرب
مدفعي وقذاف زنانات واحنا ماشين بالسياره
قنا اثنين شع اول شارع القرمان حملناهم
وجبناه على المستشفى هي اللي صار قذف
مستمر في اغلب المطب تلاقي في قذف مستمر
نزلوا مدانين هي مره حاملين الرز على
الزلمه معه كيس رز وكيس حليب ل صغار شويه
وكيس حطب صغير معه يعني هدول شخصين جابو
لنا اياهم من بيت
حنون باقيين رايحين على بيوتهم يجيبوا
منها مون لاولادهم اكل وشرب فتم قصفهم في
بيت حنون في منطقه القرمان رجل وامراه
مجهولين الهويه لم يتم التعرف عليهم حتى
[موسيقى]
الان الله يسهل عليك يما استودعتك الله يا
رب تعوضنا خير يا رب عن كل الشباب اللي
راحت يا رب ابني مابس البدنه البيضا يا رب
يا رب لبس الكفل الابيض يا رب ترحمه فر
وزوز بحور العين يا رب يا رب اجعل كل
الشهده من المقبولين يا رب يا رب تجعلنا
المحتسبين الصابرين يا رب تربط على قلوبنا
الصبر يا رب يا رب ابني طلبها ونالها طلب
جوارك يا رب طلع يقوللي انا شهيد يما اذا
القصف لم يتوقف هنا على شمال قطاع غزه
بالتحديد على بيت حانون هناك قصف مدفعي
متواصل على منازل المواطنين وعلى كل من
يحاول الوصول لمنزله مما ادى لوقوع عدد من
شهداء تم انتشال هؤلاء الشهداء من قبل
الاهالي ووصولهم الى هنا الى مستشفى كمال
عدوان ما زال عدد من الشهداء في الطرقات
لم تتمكن الطواقم الطبيه من انتشالهم او
الوصول اليهم انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه